I like the story about when you skived off school to do your
The big audition for New Faces. Yeah, which was the big kind of talent show at the time. Yeah
New Faces was like x-factor or The Voice
but for Britain's Got Talent actually had judges and everything and I've been nominated to go on by DJ Mike my manager and
I snuck I had to sneak out of the house early because mom didn't know I was gonna play truant from school
I put on my Sunday school clothes because they were the best clothes I had
when I went to Birmingham to this club with a very sticky carpet that smelled of wee
We waited all day and then at 6 o'clock. I went onstage and it was the most glorious thing
The judges have been saying next all day
but this was the first time they hadn't said next and suddenly I had the golden ticket and I'd got through and it was
fantastic and DJ Mike drove me back home to Dudley and he saw my mom's silhouette in the window and he drove off really quick
'Cause he knew what was going to happen
So I went to the front door and mum was standing in the front door where you been
I said I went to an audition
Audition? What kind of audition?
I went through auditions on New Faces.
New Faces?
hmm
What you do down there?
Impressions what you mean impressions do it now what?
So she made me do the impressions on
My front doorstep if you want to come in this house and eat chicken rice and peas and jerk gravy you better do the impressions right now
So thank you very much I better start the show
I was a joke the other day
If you take off all your clothes and stand by the window I said, why? He said I can't stand my neighbor's
Here's a funny this is max bar games
You've never heard of Max Bar Games have you or the Millennials going what's Lenny talking about but there was this guy called Max
Bar Games, and he used to talk like this. I went to the dentist the other day
He said, "Say 'Ah'". I said "why" He said "me dog's dead".
Then there was a show. Michael Crawford had a show called some mothers do ave em
And they used to talk like this
And the I had a ploughman's lunch the other day it was furious
I was sixteen!
It was the 70's
That's the kind of stuff they laughed at then. Anyway
I did this thing and what was wonderful was my family
My cousin's my brothers and sisters gave me a round of applause and it was the first time that acknowledged
That I was this other person. Yeah, I wasn't the Lynne from inside the house. I was Lenny from outside the house
And Lennie outside the house did this stuff with his mates and it was a kind of revelation
But it was also a wonderful homecoming for me. Yeah, because they suddenly started to go. Oh yeah Len's the one who does the voices
You